and my own dreams
are in creating uh robots
and artificial intelligence systems that
a human can love
and i think there's something
about uh mortality and fear mortality
that is essential
for implementing in our ai systems
yeah and so maybe can you comment on
that like
well uh on uh
so this is this is a different
perspective on on your work sure which
is like
how do we engineer a human yeah so no
this is awesome lex i'm delighted that
you said that first of all
and i may mention this to you and i
don't i can't remember because i am seen
out
when you first contacted me yeah
i had just been told i have to learn
more about your work
because i'm working with some very
talented people in new york
and they're they're writing a screenplay
uh for a movie about
an artificial intelligence it's a female
a.i set in like 30 years
in the future and
basically the little twist this is how i
had to read heidegger so these people
call me
and they're like we're making a movie
it's based on
becker and your work and heidegger
and this other philosopher levynos
and then another philosopher sylvia
benso who's an italian philosopher
and the long short story is the movie is
about
supposedly the most advanced artificial
intelligence entity
an embodied one and
who human form human form
who finds out who is having
uh having essentially existential
and the i think the project is called a
dinner with her
or something and it doesn't really
matter but the punchline is that
she finds out that her creator
has made her
mortal and so the question is
what happens phenomenologically and
behaviorally to
an an artificial intelligence
who now knows that it's
mortal and it's actually the same
question
that you're posing yeah and that is is
that
necessary in order
for an ai to approximate
humanity yeah i think yeah so the
intuition again it's uh it's unknown but
i think it's absolutely i think it's
absolutely necessary
um a lot of people
this the same kind of shallow thinking
that people have about our own
end of life our own death is the same
way people think of i think about
artificial intelligence
it's like well okay so yeah so within
the system there's a
there's a terminal position where like
there's there's a there's a point
which it ends you just the program ends
uh there's a goal state there's a
you reach the end point but the thing is
uh making that end
a thing that's also within the program
like like the making the thing like
and then it's also the mystery of it so
the thing is
we don't know what the hell this death
thing is
i mean it's not like um it's not like we
i mean the program doesn't give us
information about the meaning of it all
exactly and the that's where the terror
is i
and and i it feels like i mean uh in the
language that you
you would think about is um is
the terror of this death or like
anticipation of it or thinking about it
is the creative force that builds
everything
right and that feels like uh
you know that feels really important to
implement
again it's very difficult to know how to
do technically
currently but it's important to think
about what i find is
you mentioned like screenplays and so on
is
sci-fi folks and philosophers are the
the only ones thinking about it
currently and that's what
these folks have convinced me yeah and
engineers aren't
which is uh i get
yeah most of the most most of the things
i talk about i get kind of
um people roll their eyes from the
engineering person not these folks
that they're like because like again i
saw your name and they're like wait a
minute i've just seen that
they're like here's someone you should
check out
yeah so this was a delightful confluence
yeah i was a huge fan of um
your work and ernest becker and um
it's funny that not enough people are uh
talking about it yeah i don't know what
to do with that i think
that there's a possibility to create
real deep meaningful connections between
ai systems and humans absolutely and um
i think some of these things of fear
mortality are essential
that are essential for the element of
human experience i don't
i don't think it might be essential to
create general intelligence like
very intelligent machines but to create
a machine that connects to a human in
some deep way
what's your view not to make me the
interviewer but what's your view
about um machine
ethics can you imagine an ethical
ai without some semblance
of yeah that's a finitude let's say
well i i think ethics uh
it's a you know there's a there's a
trolley problem that's often
used in the work that i've done yeah
yeah with uh with autonomous vehicles in
particular
oh yeah yeah uh that people
i think they offload they ask like how
would a machine deal with an ethical
situation
that they themselves humans don't know
how to deal exactly
and so i don't know
if a machine is able to uh do a better
job on
difficult ethical questions but i
certainly think to behave
properly and effectively in this world
it needs to be
uh have a fear of mortality and like
be able to even dance because i don't
think you can
solve ethical problems but you have to
uh i think like ethics is like a dance
floor
you have to just you have to uh dance
properly with the rest of the humans
like if people are dancing tango you
have to dance in the same kind of way
and for that you have to have a few
immortality like i think of
uh more practically speaking like i said
autonomous vehicles
like the way you interact with
pedestrians
fundamentally has to have a sense of
mortality
so uh when pedestrians cross the road
and now i've watched
well certainly 100 plus hours of
pedestrian videos
there's a kind of social uh contract
where you walk in front of a car
and you're putting your life in the
hands of another human being that's
right
and like death is is uh is in the car
like in the game that's being played
death is right there
uh it's part of the calculus it's not
but it's not
like a simple calculator it's not a
simple equation it's uh
it's an it's a i mean i don't know what
it is but it's it's in the it's in there
and uh it has to be part of the
optimization problem
like it's not as simple as so from the
computer vision from the
artificial intelligence perspective it's
detecting there's a human
estimating right right estimating the
trajectory
like treating everything like it's a
billiard balls
as opposed to like being able to
construct
an effective model the world model of
the
what the person is thinking what they're
going to do what are the different
possibilities of how the scene might
evolve
i think requires having some sense
of yeah fear of fear of mortality of
mortality i don't see the the thing is i
think it's really important to think
about
i can be honest enough to say that it's
i haven't been able to figure out
how to engineer any of these things
right but i do think it's really
really important like i have uh so i
have a bunch of roombas here
i can show it to you after uh that i've
roombas is a robot that has um
vacuums the floor and i've had them um
make different sounds like i had them
scream in pain
and it it uh
it uh you immediately anthropomorphized
absolutely
and it creates a i don't know
knowing that they can feel pain but see
i'm
i'm speaking like knowing uh that i
immediately imagine that they can feel
pain and it mean
it immediately draws me closer to them
yes at the human experience
and that there's there's something in
that that should be engineered
in our in our systems it feels like
i i believe personally i don't know what
you think but uh
i believe it's possible for a robot and
a human to fall in love for example in
the
in the future oh i think it's yeah it's
already there
no there's a certain kind of deep
connection with technology yeah
in a real like you would choose to marry
um
i mean again it sounds uh i'll find a
book title and i'll send it to you and
it's a serious
consideration of people
who started out with the sex dolls
but it turned into a relationship of
enduring significance that the woman who
wrote the book is not
willing to dismiss as a perversion yeah
that's what uh
you know people kind of joke about sex
robots which is funny
uh like it's a it's a funny i mean
there's a lot of stuff about robots
which is kind of fun to talk about that
is it's not necessarily connected to
reality
uh people joke about sex robots but if
you actually look how sex robots which
are pretty rare
these days are used they're not
used by people who want sex
precisely they're actually uh their
companions they're competing they become
companions yeah
it's uh yeah it's fascinating and
they're just
we're not even talking about any kind of
intelligence we're talking about just
i mean human beings seek companionships
we're deeply lonely
i mean that was the other sense i have
that i don't know if i can articulate
clearly you can probably do a better job
but
i have a sense that there's a deep
loneliness within all of us
absolutely in the face of death it feels
like we're
alone so you know the what drew me
to the existential take on things
lex was the uh
who is it rallo may and irwin
yalum write about existentialism and
they're like look it
what there's different flavors of
existentialism
but they all have in common what is it
for
universal concerns the overriding one is
about death
and that next is
choice and responsibility the next one
is
existential isolation and they're like
that's one of the
things about consciousness that and the
last one is meaninglessness but the
existential isolation point is
you know we
are by virtue of consciousness
able to apprehend that
unless you're a siamese twin you are
fundamentally alone and
because it is claimed it's eric frohm
in a book called escape from freedom
he's like look you
you're smart enough to know that the
most direct way that we typically
communicate with our fellow human beings
is through language
but you also know that language is a
pale shadow of the totality of our
interior
phenomenological existence therefore
there's always going to be times in our
lives where even under the best of
circumstances
you could be trying desperately to
convey
your thoughts and feelings and somebody
listening could be like yeah i get it i
get it i get it
and you're like you have no [ __ ] idea
what i'm talking about
yeah so you can be desperately lonely
in a house where you live with 10 people
in the middle of tokyo where there's
millions
yeah yeah it's the great gatsby yeah
you'll be alone precisely party
exactly
you